yeah i think it is this is definitely an
interesting
tool of storytelling it has struggled
with mathematics which is interesting or
in just even numbers
it's able to it's not able to generate
like
patterns you know like you give it um
in like five digit numbers and it's not
able to figure out the sequence
you know or like uh i didn't look in
too much but i'm talking about like
sequences like the fibonacci numbers and
to see how far it can go
because obviously it's leveraging stuff
from the internet and it starts to lose
it but it is also cool
that i've seen it able to generate some
interesting patterns
that are mathematically correct yeah i i
honestly haven't dug into
like what's going on within it uh in a
way that i can speak intelligently to
i guess it doesn't surprise me that it's
bad at numerical patterns because
i mean maybe i should be more impressed
with it but like that requires having
um a weird combination of intuitive
and uh and formulaic world view
so you're not just going off of
intuition when you see fibonacci numbers
you're not saying like intuitively what
do i think will follow the 13
like i've seen patterns a lot where like
13s are followed by 21s
instead it's the like the way you're
starting to see a shape of things
is by knowing what hypotheses to test
where you're
saying oh maybe it's generated based on
the previous terms or maybe it's
generated based on like multiplying by a
constant or
whatever it is you like have a bunch of
different hypotheses and your intuitions
are around those hypotheses but you
still need to actively
test it um and it seems like gpt3 is
extremely good at
um like that sort of pattern matching
recognition that
usually is very hard for computers that
um is what humans get good at
through expertise and exposure to lots
of things it's why it's good to learn
from as many examples as you can
rather than just from the definitions
it's to get that level of intuition
but to actually concretize it into a
piece of math
you do need to um like test your
hypotheses and if not prove it
um like have an actual explanation for
what's going on
not just a uh a pattern that you've seen
yeah and but then the flip side to play
devil's advocate
that's a very kind of probably correct
intuitive understanding of
just like we said a few a few layers
creating abstractions
but it's been able to form
something that looks like a
a compression of the data that it's seen
that looks
awfully a lot like it understands what
the heck is talking about
well i think a lot of understanding is
like i don't mean to
denigrate pattern recognition pattern
recognition is most of understanding and
it's super important and it's super hard
um and so like when it's demonstrating
this kind of real understanding
compressing down
some data like that that might be
pattern recognition at its finest
my only point would be that like what
differentiates math
i think to a large extent is that um the
pattern recognition isn't sufficient
and that the kind of patterns that
you're recognizing are
not like the end goals but instead
they're they are the little bits and
paths that get you to the end goal
so that's certainly true for mathematics
in general it's an interesting question
if
that might for a certain kinds of series
of numbers
it might not be true like you might
because that's a basic
you know like taylor's like certain
kinds of series it feels like
compressing the internet
is is enough to figure out because those
patterns in some form appear
in the text somewhere yeah well i mean
there's uh there's all sorts of
wonderful examples of false patterns in
math where
um one of the earliest videos i put on
the channel was talking about
you're kind of dividing a circle up
using these chords and you see this
pattern of one two four
eight sixteen that's like okay pretty
easy to see what that pattern is it's
powers of two
you've seen it a million times um but
it's not powers of two the next term is
31.
and so it's like almost a power of two
but it's a little bit shy
and there's there's actually a very good
explanation for what's going on um
but i think it's a good test of whether
you're thinking
clearly about mechanistic explanations
of things
how quickly you jump to thinking it must
be powers of two because the problem
itself there's really no
no good way to i mean there can't be a
good way to think about it as
like doubling a set because ultimately
it doesn't but even before it starts to
it's not something that
screams out as being a doubling
phenomenon so at best if it did turn out
to be powers of two it would have only
been so very subtly
and i think the difference between like
you know a math student making the
mistake and a mathematician who's
experienced
seeing that kind of pattern is that they
they'll have a sense from what the
problem itself
is whether the pattern that they're
observing
is reasonable and how to test it and
like
uh i would just be very impressed if
there was any algorithm that
um was actively accomplishing that goal
yeah like a learning based algorithm
yeah like a little scientist i guess
yeah basically
yeah it's a it's a fascinating thought
because gpg3
these language models are already
accomplishing way more than i've
expected so
i'm learning not to doubt i bet we'll
get there
yeah i'd be i'm not saying i'd be
impressed but like surprised like i'll
be impressed but i i think we'll get
there on
um algorithms doing math like that
you